the anxiety rates are off the charts the
suicide rates are higher than ever so
many things that they did that we just
will never have any kind of recourse for
but yeah what you described was a really
damaging era in the lives of children
that they'll never get back that's it
that childhood moment is gone
um I think part of it is that and going
back to that forced Conformity it's a
way of dividing us it's like what's a
woman what's you know we don't even know
what this means like these are these are
words that have no meaning
um it's a way of making sure that we
stay divided and don't unite over
anything so that they can keep us in
control and that they can keep the kids
indoctrinated
foreign
class related to all of this so talking
about like the teacher class and the
administrators whether it's at a school
or at a hospital like were any of them
trying to fight too so part of the
problem is that the people who give them
their licensing uh the for doctors for
example or teachers colleges are very
um leftist and they teach them how to be
indoctrinators I think Bethany could
speak more to the licensing she wrote
the chapter on it in our book yeah so
one of the scariest parts that sort of
came out of covid
um was that if you were accused of
spreading misinformation and
misinformation was narrowly defined as
covenness information but now it's
defined more broadly into any
misinformation and so you know
reproductive health and the in the wake
of Roe versus Wade falling if you're
spreading misinformation about
reproductive Health your license is at
risk and so I wrote a piece for the
spectator about the fall of Roe versus
Wade and all these things and no one
would talk to me on the record because
they said I I can lose my license and
who defines misinformation and who makes
these decisions all of it is secret and
so I can just get a letter one day that
says I've had my license revoked and so
all of this is permeating through
licensing for Psychiatry for medical to
get into med school you have to answer
questions that you know it's a litmus
test how will you implement Dei in your
professional life as as a medical
professional of any kind
um which basically means kill more white
people right like and at some level
right like if you want equity and health
like yeah I mean what we saw with the
code vaccinations the first priority in
what state was it I think well I think
um I think Oregon did it too or maybe
the city of Portland or something yeah
so you didn't get it first if you were a
white male yeah tough luck Gotta Wait
well in actuality it was probably pretty
good but that wasn't that wasn't the
intention what about the psychological
level for your kids because I remember
at the height of covid craziness I
hadn't seen my family in like six months
I was like forget this I'm going back to
New York just to see my parents and and
see my nieces and nephew and nephews and
I go into my nephew's room and I think
he was in sixth grade at the time maybe
fifth grade and he's got a computer and
he's uh he's in school but like he was
also like playing on his switch and like
doing his thing and I was like yeah and
like what's what's the deal with this
and he's like it's so stupid like
everybody knows it's stupid nobody's
paying attention like in the most pure
innocent possible way right
um but the way they destroyed like kids
absolutely the anxiety rates are off the
charts the suicide rates are higher than
ever
um so many things that they did that we
just will never have any kind of
recourse for but yeah what you described
was a really damaging era in the lives
of children that they'll never get back
that's it that childhood moment is gone
um I think part of it is that and going
back to that forced Conformity it's a
way of dividing us it's like what's a
woman what's you know we don't even know
what this means like these are these are
words that have no meaning
um it's a way of making sure that we
stay divided and don't unite over
anything so that they can keep us in
control and that they can keep the kids
indoctrinated yeah yeah and again like
this goes way past just covid but covet
was was a great accelerator for all of
this stuff and you know you can't
revolutionize an entire society when
everyone is happy and content exactly
and so the misery and the anxiety and
the depression of all these kids is the
goal because that's how you further
change because they see that stuff is
messed up and they they need to fix it
and so you know who care I mean who
cares if they lose a couple in the ends
justify the means yeah well that's why I
do believe it's intentional now I I used
to try my best and I still do to some
degree to not go after everybody's
motives but after I mean you I think
moved here a day before I did to Florida
right or the day after me we're right
there right we like landed like probably
within 24 hours of each other up and our
lives come here now you're year your
kids are going to school there's no
chance they're going to be masked or
forced that changes literally everything
right and again it's not just the
masking right because apparently we're
past covid Joe Biden says
um but for that emergency orders
right it's coming
um but you know the the whole Ron
DeSantis not allowing woke nonsense in
schools which means that my kids who are
in public school I feel safer with them
at at those schools and I I'm not I
don't worry about them as much um they
don't have like 12 trans friends each
because it just hasn't hit here in the
same way that hit New York but the thing
that we always say is that you shouldn't
feel
safe and confident if you live in a red
area it's coming to you to the teachers
go to the teachers colleges where they
learn Marxism which they pass along to
your children this is happening
everywhere I've heard we heard from
people in small towns and rural areas
and deep red States and they were all
saying my kids are getting it too what
do you say is the ultimate answer to
this at the school level I mean is it
pure School of Choice and funding
students instead of systems instead of
systems and doing the homeschooling
thing I mean is it basically
obliterating we have education as we
know it we have different paths but you
talk about yours first yeah so we
homeschool and I have no intention of
doing otherwise I mean I don't live in a
red State I live in the most liberal
County in a quite liberal State I live
Montgomery County Maryland why is
Montgomery County gone so bananas every
time uh every time I see something out
of Montgomery it's like as it's like
Beyond World it seems like it's part of
it is because a lot of us journalist
folks live there and so that's it we I
mean
that crazy right so the stories that we
are we are getting published on Fox News
and I like I have a hand in a lot of
them yeah a lot of the stuff that gets
published I'm feeding to people because
it's not my zone but I want it out there
and it's because I have the privilege of
having the email address of a Fox news
reporter
um there's people in Indiana and in
Oklahoma who don't have that privilege
doesn't mean it's not happening there
and so you know for us like we
homeschool and we are very choosy about
the friends that our kids have but I I
mean I my DMs on Twitter are a
repository of all of the crazy mcps
stories but what's really sort of crazy
is that they are so open about it
they're so proud about it and so a lot
of the stuff that I end up passing on to
Fox news reporters is stuff that they've
posted publicly
well it's sort of like Libs of tick tock
right like people were like oh she's
attacking these people but literally
she's reposting their own videos so how
do you differ in terms of that I mean
kids are
we really lay the line
this is what we believe leave and these
are the values that we want you to carry
out into the world and so a lot of it
requires being really honest with our
children about our beliefs because
parents say that oh we don't we don't
really talk about with our kids about
that well we don't talk about
necessarily politics we don't talk to
them about like which political
candidates we like or anything like that
um but we do talk to them about values
and that's important you want to get the
message to your kids and you want to lay
the foundation for them because a lot of
the time you will have to let them go
eventually they will get to college and
they'll be they'll face this wokeness no
matter how much you've protected them
and it's important that they know where
they came from yeah and and I I mean not
just tell them but also live it I mean
they watched me scream at Montgomery
County the County Council on Zoom
meetings and I would sit there for an
hour and 45 minutes and they never tell
you your time slot for speaking for two
minutes so you have to sit there and so
there's one video of me holding one of
my babies and they turn on the camera
and you're I was the first one
testifying for this portion of the
County Council bill and so I just let
loose and started screaming at them and
my kids at the end of it were like first
of all you're terrifying I do not want
to go inside school tomorrow
they like sort of avoided me for the
next four hours but they saw that I was
screaming about them I was yelling at
them about how kids were being treated
about how my son was yelled at in a
supermarket because he wasn't wearing a
mask because I wasn't just because I'll
play along to go into the supermarket
doesn't mean I'm gonna make my kids to
do it and so my kid got yelled at in the
supermarket and I said this is your
fault Montgomery County Public like the
County Council and they saw I was
fighting for them and that is really
powerful and they got it if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell